c'était cet après-midi au salon bleu de
l'assemblée nationale philippe couillard
avec son premier discours d'ouverture
tu ouvrais la 41ème session législative
ici à québec
du coup il ya beaucoup beaucoup insisté
on l'a dit si vous étiez avec nous en
début d'émission sur les finances
publiques le défi des finances publiques
en 2010 on dépense plus que ce que l'on
reçoit comme revenu donc on aura des
choix difficiles ce monde a été repris à
plusieurs reprises on a donné des
exemples dans le bulletin un peu plus
tôt cimenterie de port-daniel c'est loin
d'être sûr également csdm commission
scolaire de montréal 25 postes dont des
psychothérapeutes donc des gens qui
travaillent avec les enfants le service
à la population
j'ai rencontré le premier ministre il ya
quelques minutes en lui demandant ce que
on peut compresser sans couper les
services aux citoyens
paul en entrevue bonsoir bonsoir vous
senti soulagé c'est ça y est c'est fait
je compte engranger 2 j'ai eu et j'ai eu
beaucoup de plaisir à le préparer et l
le livre est également c'est un moment
important dans la vie d'un gouvernement
dans ma vie politique dans ma vie
personnelle même et je suis heureux de
l'avoir fait vous dites vous êtes
heureux tout ça mais c'est un discours
quand même assez sombre même si tout ça
était donné dans le calme vous brosser
un tableau assez noir des finances
publiques du québec décembre le premier
s quoi justement donnez nous la mesure
est ce qu'on est d'après vous vraiment
au bord du précipice
on est près du mur il est pas loin du
tout écoutez on est si on ne faisait
rien on est à 5 milliards de déficit
pour l'année 14 15 7 milliards l'année
suivante
donc si on laisse les choses aller on
perd toute notre capacité d'agir tout
notre liberté de choix tout la capacité
de soutenir de programmes qui nous sont
très chers alors y ait pas hypothétique
de vouloir corriger des finances
publiques est une obligation qu'on a
envers nous et les prochaines
générations parce que certains qui
prétend que vous noir si c'est par choix
politique le tableau pour pouvoir faire
un certain nombre prendre un certain
nombre de décisions
vous dites nous sommes prêts quoi d'une
décote
on a déjà eu une perspective négative
par une agence de crédit je peux lancer
les quais dessus dessous cette question
là parce que on voudrait certainement
pas avoir à affronter cesse
situation est au contraire le fait
d'avoir la rigueur budgétaire con qu'on
propose de fait de relancer l'économie
également parce qu'il s'agit pas que de
rigueur budgétaire il s'agit également
de relancer l'économie créer de l'emploi
il faut faire les deux l'expérience
internationale le montre que quand on
fait que la rigueur ou les coupes
budgétaires souvent au ralenti
l'économie et on se tire dans le pied
comme on dit chez nous y'a plus de 50 %
des dépenses de l'état c'est des
salaires monsieur gougnan reste que ça
veut dire au bout de l'exercice
on fera pas l'économie de mises à pied
ou de baisses de salaires les salaires
on veut qu'ils demeurent bons la
fonction publique on veut que les jeunes
viennent et reste travail et de la
fonction publique mais il faut
certainement regarder oui les salaires
mais le nombre est là il ya des
circonstances naturel pour une fois qui
nous aide c'est que la démographie ça en
fait en sorte qu' il ya environ quinze
mille personnes par année qui quêtent
les services publics au québec alors
faut s'assurer de gérer ça correctement
de prioriser les endroits où on donne
des services à la population diminue et
la lourdeur dante appareil
bureaucratique et avec ça de maintien au
service alors il ya une question de
salaire mais il ya surtout une question
de nombre il faut que les deux
fonctionnent ensemble mais quand vous
dites ça et vous n'êtes pas le premier
effectivement au ça donne l'impression
que ça va se faire naturellement et
doucement je vous donne un exemple
aujourd'hui on le verra dans le but un
nouvel un peu plus tard commission
scolaire de montréal et à 25 mises à
pied ils doivent donc aussi travailler
sur leurs budgets mais c'est pas des
gens qui comptaient des choses
abstraites cdc dz la psychologie c'est
des aides pour les devoir céder des gens
qui travaillent avec des enfants en
difficulté ça c'est des vrais
compression qui vont faire mal on les
devants sol on veut éviter le plus
possible que les rigueurs budgétaires et
des impacts négatifs sur les services à
la population par un ciblant d'autres
types d'actions
et soyons clairs on va poser des actions
et c'est toujours la même chose quand un
gouvernement
ici comme ailleurs doit s'engager dans
une opération de restriction de rigueur
budgétaire les voix s'élèvent pour dire
qu'on noirci le tableau qu'il faut pas
faire ça et elles sont allons les
paralysés on tourne en rond c'est encore
pire l'année suivante alors on va mener
cette question là avec fermeté cette
année c'est le budget de transition mais
il faut revenir par la suite de façon à
être libéré de cet exercice qui
franchement devient lassant pour tout le
monde
de compression de décompression et la
façon d'y arriver c'est de réviser notre
fiscalité et faire introduire au
gouvernement du québec une culture
permanente pas temporaire de révision
des programmes
vous avez utilisé l'expression dans
votre discours d'ouverture coup de frein
et les robes des coups de frein ici et
là vous avez parlé d'une dame aux îles
de la madeleine mais je vous parlais des
parents de saint bruno et qu'ils ont vu
à trois semaines un sérieux coup de
frein leur garderie étaient prêtes les
noms des petits-enfants étaient collées
sur les murs il manquait que je vais
reconduire mon enfant dans deux semaines
or laminé sano gèle tout ça est ce que
c'est un exemple ce qui va arriver de
plus dans ces cas précis
clovis a été corrigé la cnra tout toutes
les classes qui était prévu pour l'année
prochaine - mise en place on doit
évaluer ce service là non pas pour
l'abolir mais pour s'assurer au contrat
de pouvoir le préserver et de protéger
en particulier les familles de classe
moyenne une famille de classe avec un
revenu plus bas des impacts tarifaire
qu'une augmentation soudaine de tarifs
pour entraîner personnes se scandalise
que pour des gens à revenus plus élevés
que le tarif soit plus élevé là où on
est inquiet c'est que l'impact par
exemple la hausse proposée de 7 à 9 pour
une famille de classe moyenne avec
revenus plutôt bas deux enfants c'est
1000 $ par année c'est considérable
comme impact
alors il doit y avoir un moyen cette
façon organisée de veiller à protéger
nos cerveaux de garde parce que donner
un qui pour la société mais de protéger
cette partie de la population est encore
là on est de 20 des exemples qui vont se
multiplier vous dites c'était une erreur
car la véritable y quelques jours après
on a fait savoir à cette garderie l'oeil
aux autres que ceux qui avaient reçu les
derniers dernière étant de dix ans 6300
places prévues pour l'année vont être
bon il avait été bloqué parce qu'il y
avait eu un moddeur de tous les faits a
été clarifiée rapidement puis moi je
veux pas qu'on procède de cette façon là
justement parce que lorsqu'on aura des
commentaires à faire sur les services de
garde
ils seront faits avec si je peux me
permettre l'expression l'armature d'une
opération sérieuse de révision de
programmes mais ça veut dire quand même
à terre moins de places dans les
garderies que prévu ça veut dire moins
de servais ça veut dire moins de
professionnels dans les écoles et l'orge
pas d'accord avec vous mais ça va être
une personne nécessairement si on révise
les programmes qu'on décide des
priorités il est clair que les services
à la petite enfance une priorité
et quand même des ressources au bon
endroit dans les services directs plus
doux qu'à d'autres endroits et qu'on a
juste notre tarification de façon à
protéger les gens famille les familles à
revenus plus bas alors au contraire est
au dessus de tout ça monsieur roy si on
garde des finances publiques dans l'état
où elles sont on va les perdre de
service public la plus grande menace à
nos services publics c'est pas
l'exercice de rigueur de l'année en
cours c'est de garder cette perspective
de déficit déficit structurel au québec
qui est devant nous actuellement
c'est de ça qu'il faut se libérer hockey
est ce que dans ce contexte vous paix
vous l'avez dit aujourd'hui vous
continuez par ailleurs vous dites la
joute 44 groupes de familles médecine
familiale 50 super qui ne vous ai pas
parlé des infirmières oui affirme urbain
j'ai moins 2000 superinfirmières donc
parallèlement à ce resserrement des
finances vous dit on va réinvestir dans
ses gants tout ce qui a trait aux
services directs aux gens puis vous avez
cité des exemples importants pour voler
mesure et on va les surveiller de très
près la philosophie qu'on veut envoyer
dans l'administration publique c'est des
opérations budgétaires en cours
nécessaires doivent le plus possible
épargner services directs à la
population et surtout touché l'appareil
administratif de l'état de façon à nous
donner l'espace pour faire la révision
de programmes ce que je veux pas qu'on
fasse et les opérations majeures dans
des services ou des programmes avant
qu'on ait fait de l'opération de
révision de programmer l'envoi très
transparent la première avec la
population de député ce programme là il
est très pertinent mais il ya pas assez
de ressources ou à l inverse il faut
réviser sa pertinence et des ressources
qui sont à l'aise j'avais dit ce n'est
pas parce qu'il ya un besoin que l'état
doit absolument arriver avec un
programme est donné un exemple de sa
boîte et je vais donner un exemple qui a
défrayé l'actualité à quelques reprises
la fertilisation de vitraux c'est un
besoin naturel des familles puis soyons
clairs je vais pas tourner le dos aux
programmes là il est en place mais on a
très envie
on dirait que non on va le faire
différemment on voit l'administré mieux
et surtout on veut garder ses effets
bénéfiques qui sont sans quoi le fait
que les familles à revenus plus bas
auront accès à cette technologie le fait
qu'on a réussi à diminuer le nombre de
grossesses multiples ce qui est un
acquis pour la société en termes de les
coûts pour les soins de santé
alors il faut juste développer le
réflexe que quand un nouveau besoin et
d'entrer dans la société que l'épaule
l'état et pas se précipiter sous des
pressions extérieures
vers la création d'un nouveau programme
premièrement et deuxièmement que si on
accepte qu'il faut créer un nouveau
progrès en titre choix légitime pour la
population que ce soit compensé par les
économies ailleurs également et que
ledit programme je termine là dessus n'a
pas nécessairement c'est la deuxième
partie du paragraphe n'a pas
nécessairement être le programme le plus
luxueux où le plus généreux du canada
c'est pas pour ça qu'on est moins
solidaire ou moins démocrate parents de
solidarité votre minet de la santé voice
est assez ironique va demander à ses
anciens collègues de reprendre une
partie de ce qu'il avait négocié avec
vous alors monsieur se retourne à ses
anciens collègues vous savez vous ce que
je faisais vous obtenu la lune pour vous
ordonniez une partie on parle de
tellement ouais je pense que l'étalement
ironie avec consentement c'est tout le
monde l'a fait trop généreux tout le
monde doit faciliter dans les
circonstances il fallait faire un effort
pour rapprocher la rémunération des
médecins de la moyenne canadienne c'est
ce qui a été fait maintenant il est pas
vrai que les médecins m'ont échappé aux
efforts qu'on demande à toute la société
puis à tous les programmes publics
actuellement et on va les traiter avec
justice et son gant ont respecté entente
on veut les étaler dans le temps et
c'est très légitime de le faire ce
premier ministe de trois questions
rapides vous ai parlé du pétrole mais de
façon assez lointaine anticosti est ce
que c'est un feu vert ou un flot va vous
revenir là dessus prochainement parce
que je veux aborder la question
globalement ils n'ont pas de façon
ponctuelle contrat qui a dû jouer on va
parler aussi un jour on parle
d'anticosti l'autre jour on parle de old
harry l'autre jour on parle des
pipelines l'autre jour on parle du gaz
naturel
on va présenter une approche cohérente
et l'art de la question des
hydrocarbures qui va bien sûr parler
d'anticosti
mais qui va parler de la façon dont on
veut on peut de façon responsable
exploiter ses ressources ce n'est pas
évident que le contrat signé vont être
on va aller de l'avant comme on l'avait
prévu sous l'enseigné fait des remarques
quand je t'aime à nos positions que je
maintiens aujourd'hui la génétique et la
queue pas contre l'exploitation du mal
ce n'est sur la répartition du risque
entre l'état donc on parle de l'état
c'est vous et moi c'est le contribuable
et les gens qui nous écoutent et le
partenaire privé sinon un trip
port-daniel en gaspésie vous aviez dit
en campagne moi je suis pour puis région
qui a besoin d'emplois or votre minet
sdao dit aujourd'hui ben on regarde ça
c'est l'état qui prend tous les risques
dans notre exemple
c'est un autre exemple mais selon
monsieur que monsieur le goûte pas
contents qu'on trouve aujourd'hui
il reprend exactement ce que je disais
oui ou non à la cimenterie
alors là aussi on fait l'examen de ce
projet là moi je veux créer de l'enfant
en gaspésie je suis préoccupé par le
sort économique de la gaspésie qui est
une région particulière avec des besoins
particuliers de se revoir le paramètre à
me relire tout cela je sais ça que j'ai
demandé à faire à monsieur de où c'est
quoi la répartition du risque entre les
deux c'est quoi qui arrive si
malheureusement l'entreprise à des
difficultés qui paye
qu'est ce qui arrive chez des
dépassements qui paye en premier c'est
des questions légitimes non on va y
revenir au cours des prochains jours des
prochaines semaines mais on va remettre
en question concernant le but le projet
va de l'avant mais on va vérifier le
l'entente et moi je veux m'assurer ce
sera le cas dans tous les projets futurs
dans lequel le gouvernement investira on
veut pas un gouvernement de subventions
uniquement aux vins nos partenaires
également qu'on dit partenaires c'est
qu'on partage également les risques et
les bénéfices parler de projet hier on
avait un reportage au téléjournal le
grand montréal sur le slr le drain donc
léger sur rail entre la rive sud et
montréal sur le futur pont chambre et
l'ancien gouvernement avait dit on y va
avec un slr c'est notre choix
qu'est ce que vous en pensez oui ou non
à un mode de transport comme celui là
oui un mode de transport sl oui un mode
de transport fiable rapide écologique ça
près d un tournage dans votre cas on est
en analyse parce qu'il a pas juste le
mode de transport il ya le coup puis
n'oublions pas que le l'argent qu'on met
dans un projet par définition on le met
pas ailleurs il ya beaucoup de besoins
dans la région montréal train de l'ouest
de la ligne bleue vers l'est
réduit au train des soucis oui on dit
encore oui mais on peut pas tout faire
en même temps et on doit faire des choix
alors il est indispensable et
incontournable qu'on ait un transport
collectif rapide et confortable
écologique entre la rive-sud sur le
nouveau pont champlain y en avoir cette
année parce que c'est pas encore
confirmé mon annoncera prochainement
dans mais ce qu'il ya c'est tout scrutin
que j'ai merci beaucoup merci d'être
d'une ouvre alors on va suivre la suite
des choses je comprends bien des
annonces qui vont venir budget 3 juin de
gea début première semaine de juin
c'est un peu tôt pour vous donner la
date exacte merci je croyais à merci